how's it going everybody today is the
first day of San Diego comic-con things
are in full motion now and one of the
first things that we've gotten is the
trailer for Titans I'll be covering
comic-con all weekend so be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date on everything that's
happening
Warren
[Music]
everything led me here to you you're the
boy from the circus please can you help
me
[Music]
we're back
there is something people inside of me
we're scared I guess but you can control
her
I don't know what has become
[Music]
sometimes when I feel the darkness it
feels good
[Music]
my mom says there's no such thing as
monsters I used to think that I was
wrong there are a lot of things to talk
about with this trailer and the first
thing is the tone it's very dark there
is a lot of blood there are some f-bombs
being thrown around there's a lot of
horror aspects to it it's dark it's easy
to see why DC is launching their own
streaming service because it's not
censored it's not regulated you can't
get away with dropping the f-bomb on the
CW the first scene sets up this dark and
ominous tone for the rest of the trailer
and the series it starts off with a
vision that Raven has of a circus which
when she goes inside she sees a sign
that says the flying Grayson's this is
obviously going to be a little bit of a
back story of how Robin came to be and
how his parents died then you have Raven
going into the police office where she
finds Robin and asks him for help now
they don't clearly state this but it's
pretty obvious what's going on here and
that is that we have detective Grayson
so it seems like what is happening here
is that we have Chuck Dixon storyline of
a Nightwing that's when Robin leaves
Batman and attempts to find himself and
create his own destiny and that clearly
seems like it's the case do you have
Robin holding his R and he throws it at
the wall very very angrily and then you
have the next scene where he takes on a
group of bad guys and they ask where's
Batman then he drops f bomb about Batman
clearly stating that he has nothing to
do with him anymore then we get a
glimpse of each of the Titans individual
powers which we haven't seen before
we've only seen like pictures of them
walking around so it's nice to finally
see how this is playing out on screen as
you see these characters it's important
to keep in mind what Jeff John said
about them he said that Rachel who is
the character Raven is the door to
horror and the supernatural Starfire is
the doorway to sci-fi Beast Boy is the
doorway to the Doom Patrol and Robin is
the doorway to the vigilantes in the DC
Universe now it looks like Raven is only
just starting to kind of discover
her powers and and a few scenes we see
her basically lose control and that's
probably Trigon taking over her mind
Trigon is a demon who impregnated her
mother so yes he's her father and he
wants to enter this world and the way
that he does that is through Ravan now
it doesn't look like they're doing the
jewel on the head thing but if you take
a look at some of these photos she's
wearing a necklace so maybe that's how
they do it it seems like the first
episode will probably be about Raven and
her mother running away from brother
blood who works for Trigon and that's
where she goes to Robin and asked him
for help now they said that season one
is primarily about Robin and Raven it's
also been said that the first episode
will be Robin Raven and Starfire and
Beast Boy won't actually run into them
yet so I'm curious to see how they
introduce Starfire and Beast Boy to
Robin and Raven when they first all meet
and start together they won't be the
Titans yet but by the end of season one
they will be we hear Raven say there's
something evil inside of me which is
obviously her father Trigon and then
Robin says you're scared I get it but
you can control it so it's clearly
setting up the dynamic between Raven and
Robin and then in the next scene we see
Starfire just roast some guys so it's
nice to see how her powers actually work
on screen her hair even lights up - it's
really cool
unfortunately Beast Boy doesn't get too
much time in this trailer but again it's
probably because he doesn't meet up with
Robin Raven and Starfire until a little
bit later on we hear Robin talking to
somebody where he says you have no idea
what I've become and here's what Jeff
Jones had to say about Robin in Titans
he said that he feels like he's been
made into a weapon and he's trying to
get away from fighting crime but things
draw him back in he's clearly talking
about when he fought with Batman and
this does go along with the story of
Nightwing where he leaves Batman so it
seems like Raven sort of draws him back
into everything by asking for help along
with the other Titans as well and
eventually throughout this series he'll
probably take on the mantle of Nightwing
the rest of the trailer is just filled
with action it's gruesome it's graphic
it's dark we even see a little cameo for
Hawk and Dove as well and they seem to
be pretty gruesome - it's just really
cool to see all of this finally come to
they're on screen it makes me really
excited for the DC streaming service
that is coming out and really excited to
see Titans when it comes out so hit me
with your thoughts and the comments
below
all of your initial reactions everything
I want to hear it hit that like button
before you leave and be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can stay
up to date with everything that is
happening at comic-con thanks for
watching woof woof
[Music]